[Musique]
c'est ouf genre l'esn szpiner la mode
est déjà passé quoi huit minutes de jeu
payer ces trucs ça vous dit on va se
bouffer un petit truc vite fait c'est
quoi cette couv vous demandez mon
coiffeur d'improviser il a improvisé
on dirait qu'on dit vicky technique de
tecktonik
c'est quoi c'est légal à l'époque ils
avaient tous les découpes de vous ferez
ça il y avait une danse ça va vous
revenir
il ya des genres tout le monde
connaissait au moins un mouvement que
l'agencé des trucs avec les bras d'un
pin pin pad à mal par un pan pan pan pan
pan pan pan
[Musique]
ça va forcément vous rappeler quelque
chose il y avait des logos des
tee-shirts
[Musique]
désolé je dois filer manger sur -
espanyol non lieu de refaire ton truc et
les bras la cheville storistes alesi
monsieur
retenue d'eau comme ça ça va je peux te
parler vite et balla suis en train de
taper mes stylos soit vraiment juge deux
secondes juste la tecktonik tu te
souviens pas je ne vois pas ce que tu
parles d'accord mais si tu sais la
tecktonik la la danse un petit peu là
c'est comme ça la clé moulinette et que
d'autres encore il a tu as des problèmes
ou quoi voilà ça existe la techno ne
suis pas fou ça existe non ça n'a jamais
existé et circuler monsieur
circuit les oublie
allez circulez
mais avant c'est dans ces marais
c'est mieux
[Musique]
crédit circule ces salades et annie bon
quand les douches
retard est embêtant c'est du bâtard
mais faute humaine tu poursuivent et je
crois qu'ils veulent me tuer [ __ ]
calmez vous calmez vous ne vous veux
aucun mal ah ouais et pourquoi vous avez
sauté sur rémy tout à l'heure alors on
me prenait pour un con ça c'était pour
son bien ok uniquement pour cent bien
mais c'est quoi le problème avec la
tecktonik la mediapad tectoniques un ya
jamais eu tectoniques tout ça c'est dans
votre tête ah ouais mais ça restait en
position le site est bien dangereux
ok ça tout de suite ok pourquoi sur l'ex
n'existait pas on s'en fout
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe tu t'inquiètes
pas tu vas vite comprendre
[Musique]
je veux savoir où on est maintenant la
plus d'eau et bafoue
la tectonique existe bien la vérité
c'est que l'état français a tellement eu
donc de ce mouvement qu'ils ont décidé
dans les passes et toutes les traces ils
ont décidé de punir tous ceux qui osent
en parler et neutraliser tous les
derniers représentants de cet art ah mon
dieu
et du coup il n'a plus à ça
[Musique]
bal à papa l'a pas la balance
bienvenue dans l'antre et puget
[Musique]
elle
encore
on tournait quel rapport avec moi je
veux dire pourquoi je suis au courant de
l'existence de la tecktonik est ce que
tu es l'un d'entre nous lui d'autres ou
devrais je dire
ludothèque quoi était l'un des meilleurs
représentants de ce mouvement hard on
sort de ta lanterne regarde regarde
cette fluidité dans les mouvements telle
une anguille
[Musique]
on a dû supprimer toute trace de ton
passé pour protéger et quand je dis
toute trace ça inclut également son
skyblog mai
[Musique]
tout est là
c'est bon
les clichés et jean n'ont pas cette date
pour toi tu es là juste à droite alors y
voit la qualité et pas folle folle mais
on joue mais je crois que c'est moi
ludothèque est de retour parmi nous
[Musique]
grâce à toi
tonique à connaître un second souffle
[Musique]
c'est donc ici votre petit qg a
carrément créé une petite discothèque à
ce que je vois sans effets ni ludothèque
la tecktonik ne survivra pas au rendez
vous si vous voulez pas que la situation
c'est pas possible tous les papas je
savais que ce moment arriverait je suis
fier de vivre à tes côtés ludothèque
il faut que j'arrête de vivre dans le
passé et que je dise à dieu msn ce que
je disait adieu à myspace
adieu
la star academy
adieu adieu la tecktonik
[Musique]
tu meurs
non
j'apprécie votre comportement et vous
savez quoi on va vous réinsérer dans la
société d'accord et puis vous inquiétez
pas il existe d'autres danses comme la
zumba par exemple
[Musique]
de se battre avec les techniques on peut
se battre
[Musique]
non